welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka
your friendly neighborhood spoiler man
and i never in a million years
thought i'd be reading the headline that
jamie foxx is returning as electro in
spider-man 3. now throughout this video
we're just going to be breaking down
that
shocking news as well as giving you the
worst puns
ever if you're new to the channel then
make sure you subscribe for videos like
this every day
and please drop a thumbs up if you if
you're laughing as much as we are
yes i cannot believe this is real now
this has just been reported by the
hollywood reporter
in the last 30 minutes and you know
they're
quite illegitimate source jamie foxx of
course played electro and the amazing
spider-man 2
but when the franchise stalled and got
cancelled by sony
his chances of returning all kind of
died out however
it looks like they're bringing it all
back together for the mcu and
you might remember that jay jonah
jameson did feature at the end of far
from home
so it looks like marvel are really
paying homage to these properties
and even beginning to include them in
their universe
now according to the article john watts
the filmmaker behind homecoming and last
year's spider-man far from home
is in the director's chair for the third
installment which sony has stated for
november 5th
2021. marvel have made no comment on the
plot just yet
but it has been confirmed that fox is
returning in this
stunning news is stunning even
electricity pun
i'll stop with the crap puns anyway now
what this does
is that it really opens the doorway to
explore the multiverse in my opinion
jay jonah jameson was sort of a tease
with this as he was of course a massive
character in the sam raimi movies
and the fact that electro is being
brought across from the amazing
spider-man franchise
does hint at the direction that the
studio is going now i would love nothing
more than to get a toby maguire
andrew garfield and tom holland team up
as they battle their villains across
multiple dimensions
and after the success of into the
spider-verse i think it would just be
absolutely amazing to see that sort of
aesthetic in live action
with jamie foxx's return i'm guessing
that's not the big draw and there will
be more to it
as as let's be honest you know he was
fine in the movie but
he wasn't the knockout signing that
you'd want to bring back for something
like this
so i have to believe that there's more
to the project but at the moment
this is all that we really know now if
you're like me and you like to
to do all the memes that were in amazing
spider-man 2
you're probably sitting reading this
article listen in this video going
you lied to me spoiler man but i swear
down
this is actually being reported right
now and it doesn't seem like anyone's
denying it
it comes from a legitimate source such
as the hollywood reporter
and yeah if this is happening you know
what
even though he wasn't my favorite
villain as i'm sure you can guess i'm
still quite hyped
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on it what your theories are
about the film itself and
and yeah just let me know in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
then please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of the finale of raised by
wolves which is going to be linked at
the end
don't forget that we're also giving away
a free copy of the marvel phase 1 box
set and all you have to do to be with
the chance of winning is like the video
drop a comment below and make sure you
subscribe with notifications on
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of october so make
sure you get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat us on the discord
server linked in the description or
heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you've been the best i've been
paul i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you